politique dans 3 jours le weekend
prochain les socialistes tiendront leur
comité directeur pour l'instant on le
sait le Parti socialiste a déjà deux
candidats à la candidature pour les
présidentielles Michel Rocard et
Jean-Pierre chevenem un double choix qui
ne fait pas l'unanimité chez les
militants socialistes alors pour mettre
tout le monde d'accord plusieurs
responsables fédéraux du Parti
socialiste ont écrit aujourd'hui à
François mitteran ils se disent prêt à
créer les conditions de sa candidature à
la tête de ce mouvement le sénateur de
lessonne Jean-Luc
Mélenchon menchon 36 ans le plus jeune
sénateur de France dirigeant des
socialistes de lessonne très lié aux
animateurs du mouvement de la jeunesse
de décembre 86 notamment Isabelle Thomas
avec qui il a signé une contribution
lors du dernier congrès il entend
incarneré la nouvelle génération du PS
résolument à gauche et décidé à imposer
une nouvelle candidature
mitteran il faut arrêter cette espèce de
danse autour du totem François miteran
voulez-vous être candidat François
mitteran soyez candidat et cetera je
crois que ça c'est une conception de de
la politique qui est complètement
archaïque on attend que un personnage se
déclare je crois que sa candidature est
tellement importante pour ce pays et
pour la gauche qu'il faut en créer les
conditions et c'est ça que nous essayons
de faire et il faut donc il participer
complètement il suffit pas d'attendre
que François mitteran dise oui ou non
François mitteran il a apporté la preuve
notamment pendant les événements de
novembre et décembre dernier qu'il avait
cette capacité d'écoute euh
d'attention à ce qui est nouveau dans la
société française à ce qui bouge lui il
a pas besoin de se mettre un wman sur la
tête pour avoir leur jeune d'ailleurs il
essaye pas crois quand on regarde par
exemple ce que disent les jeunes autour
de nous ou ce que disent les sondages il
y a une confiance il y a une sympathie à
l'égard de François mitteran qui est
très forte très profonde c'est pas pour
rien qu'on l'appelle tonton